on n'avait pas vu ça depuis très
longtemps des milliers de jeunes
londoniens qui s'apprête à se faire
vacciner contre la poliomyélite
maladie qui réapparaît alors qu'on
croyait l'avoir hérétiques et du royaume
uni la région de new york est également
touchée depuis trois semaines
l'éclosion eu lieu dans le comté de
reclus à une vingtaine de kilomètres au
nord de manhattan
l'analyse dont user du secteur laisse
croire aux autorités de la santé que des
centaines de personnes pourraient avoir
été infectées sans savoir la raison le
ton nationale de vaccination contre la
polio aux etats-unis et 2 93% mais
seulement de 60% dans rock lawn où 11
mai l'enfant de moins de deux ans ne
sont pas vaccinés
vous savez là on n'a pas pu parler du
virus de la polio mais ce virus le
circuit layar donc y est endémique en
certain niveau limité dans certains pays
on ne compterait mans vers la variole
celui ci n'a point éradiquer la
poliomyélite est une maladie très
contagieuse généralement à symptômes
atik mais qui cause parfois une
paralysie et la mort les premiers
vaccins contre la polio sont développées
durant les années 50
leur utilisation se répand rapidement
surtout chez les jeunes enfants
particulièrement vulnérables
aujourd'hui 80 % des enfants sont
vaccinés et seuls deux pays
l'afghanistan et le pakistan sont aux
prises régulièrement avec des éclosions
de polio au canada le dernier qu'a
connue remonte à plus de 25 ans mais la
ville de new york n'est pas si loin nos
frontières lorsqu'on doit surveiller
c'est ce qu'ils font en ce moment aux
états unis c'est que s'assurer que les
enfants entre autres sont plus celles
des symptômes graves s'est infectée qui
ne sont pas vaccinés aimé qu'on
encourage fortement quelle qu'elle soit
avec ce n'est plus de 90% des enfants
canadiens sont vaccinés contre la polio
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal